desde montreal un saludo a todos
nuestros oyentes e internautas que nos
acompañan en este programa semanal de
radio canadá internacional el castor
cibernético y que lo hacen a través de
facebook también del canal de youtube y
del cnt punto sea nuestro programa en la
web hoy en la mesa de trabajo está
leonardo gimeno hola leonardo pablo
gómez barrios qué tal pablo
estamos acá con muchísimas cosas para
conversar no sé si habrá tiempo para
hacerlo de todo lo que tenemos acá
planificado podemos decir antes que
antes que empecemos a tratar los temas
de leonardo que hay una nueva un nuevo
ap un aparato si es es una aplicación
una pequeña publicación cuando ustedes
entraban al sitio de internet de radio
cada interna cional deben hacerlo a
través del navegador es decir abrir si
tenían una
un teléfono inteligente desde cualquier
navegador que pueden bajar en el
teléfono inteligente el que viene por
defecto de instalado en el teléfono o
cualquier otro en este caso lo que
estamos ahora proponiéndoles les
comentamos a la gente que el equipo de
radical internacional con arséne el
webmaster del equipo chino desarrollaron
esta aplicación de pablos y lo puedes
mostrar de la aplicación de radio canadá
internación sólo tengo la tengo muy bien
entonces ustedes pueden entrar
directamente en sus teléfonos no sé si
se va a ver de cerca el hijo pero yo
tengo aquí r6 net punto sea la
aplicación 1 entra directamente en la
aplicación y abre todo el contenido de
nuestro teléfono sin ningún problema y
están todas las bueno producción con eso
leonardo velocidad que han estabilidad
si por ejemplo yo tengo mi teléfono en
inglés ahora me gusta tener el sistema
operativo en inglés yo entro a la página
por defecto entra en inglés y tengo que
cambiar de lengua y
y no es arriesgado hay que pasar a hacer
clic clic clic clic acá uno puede entrar
tanto al applestore como a play google
play y bajar la aplicación directamente
en la lengua que ustedes prefieran yo la
tengo en español aquí tengo la entrada
para el francés en inglés si quiero
hacerlo y si un poquito más lejos puedo
entrar las otras dos pero lo interesante
es para la gente que vive en canadá por
ejemplo que hablan dos o quizás más
lenguas que tengan la posibilidad de
navegar en los contenidos porque no es
necesariamente el mismo contenido en el
equipo francés que en el equipo inglés
que en el equipo español digamos se
hacen cosas originales en cada una de
las secciones entonces para poder
aprovechar de todo el contenido les
recomendamos ir a google play o app
store y bajar la aplicación de radio
canadá internacional y para la gente que
no vive en canadá y la gente que no vive
en canadá es mucho más rápido
y hay que decir para los que se
pregunten por qué no hay no existe la
aplicación para los que hablan árabe y
chino entre nuestros oyentes el que se
pregunte por qué no existe la aplicación
en árabe y chino
si existe existe
de tal manera que yo por ejemplo la bajo
en español y tengo el español es lo que
abro cuando abro la aplicación
inmediatamente después arriba tengo la
posibilidad de ir al francés o en inglés
y el que lo baje en inglés tiene inglés
por defecto y puede ir a francés y
español el que tiene en francés tiene
inglés y español que tiene en árabe
tiene francés y español y el que tiene
el chino tiene inglés y francés no
francés inglés y francés e inglés en en
el caso de las lenguas extranjeras
es decir español chino
y árabe la opción son la lengua que uno
prefiere más las dos lenguas oficiales
muy bien entonces sobre todo se gana en
rapidez me parece importante y las
imágenes son la misma en realidad es
como está condensado dentro de una
aplicación es mucho más rápido
la bajada de las imágenes uno puede
guardar elementos para leerlos después
uno puede elegir preferencias para el
tema de información y desde nuestro
reportaje muy bien o sea uno tiene la
posibilidad entrar y está separado en el
caso de español está separado por
categorías es decir que arriba usted
tiene en cartelera política sociedad
inmigración refugio y bueno en realidad
esas son las principales después uno
puede ir a buscar más puede por ejemplo
para que los que tengan como yo que
cuando tengo que leer tengo que bajar
porque no veo con mis lentes porque
tengo una presbicia la hermosísima
agrandar el tamaño de las letras de la
aplicación a leer como interesante muy
bien entonces ya saben y la pueden
descargar repetimos por vía y yo eso sea
dentro de apple store donde google play
que selecta dos tiendas de aplicaciones
de los teléfonos más conocidos está muy
bien muy bien entonces ya lo saben y
cualquier consulta nos pueden escribir y
leonardo va a contestar a sus preguntas
por si tienen dudas la semana pasada
estuvimos hablando de una nutria muy
traviesa bastante traviesa y que dio
pues su reino con el terror durante unos
diez días
todo lo posible por tradición británica
en vancouver ya les habíamos dicho la
semana pasada que bueno se había comido
s carpa col
y son pescados que tienen una
significación cultural muy grande dentro
de la comunidad china también exacto y
entre otros en el jardín chino lo que
esto pasó exacto y nosotros hablamos la
semana pasada de madonna que la gente
estaba muy preocupada pues muchos están
tristes
al parecer se la comió con la lama vio a
la madonna y madonna tenía 50 años y era
venerada por los chinos haití son peces
que tienen una significación cultural
muy importante para la comunidad china
así que los traslada a algunos los
trasladaron al acuario de vancouver pero
bueno se apareció a salvarlo al parecer
pues como no logran capturarla piensan
que ya otro cielo
desde el sábado a elvis porque le
pusieron el bis de nombre y no saben si
es un hembra o macho pero le pusieron el
bis el bis dice que no aparece desde el
sábado entonces
muy confiados que él dice le pusieron
trampas por todos lados buscando y por
ahí se había un poquito de ella asomaba
la cabeza ahí pero pero no cuentan con
la astucia de él y yo creo esto se me
parece muy rápido que hayan traído todos
los otros peces le pusieron el hipo que
es el bisturí perfecto
lo interesante en todo eso también es
que al parecer pues se han sumergido y
han ido a explorar el fondo de ese
estanque y al parecer pues hay pececitos
pequeñas entrado se sientan así han
reproducido ahí están
entonces por la gente al parecer está
muy alegre de que la regla el relevo yo
no sabía que algún pez podía llegar a
tener 50 años es para mí me sorprendió
tanto esa historia de madonna pero es
real tenía 50 años entonces pobre
madonna al término en el estómago de la
nutria hay pescados
como el estudio
donde vive el estudio
en aguas frías y así por ejemplo son y
los esturiones que te llegan a medir
como dos o tres metros hay récords
entonces o hay pescados que cuya
longevidad es realmente sorprendente
caviar para mucho tiempo porque comer es
a ese estudio de 100 años con un piñón
un vino añejado cocinaron ustedes
también hablamos la semana pasada de el
primer ministro de la provincia de
ontario que había tomado medidas para de
cortes presupuestarios en la provincia
rufo cortando entre otras cosas
y todo lo relacionado con la aplicación
de la lengua francesa en la provincia de
ontario por ejemplo cerrando una
universidad que se pensaba inaugurar y
otros temas y hay más noticias sobre eso
por un lado 6 se hizo un análisis
económico realmente porque el argumento
era que había que hacer frente al
déficit pero cuando se habla de un
presupuesto de 3 millones y medio para
la oficina de servicios a los
francófonos es nada no es ni siquiera
llega a ser un agrado de un ganado
entonces el análisis que hay una
vendetta política en a una especie de
una venganza política de parte de los
conservadores de parte de una de un
primer ministro provincial monolingüe
que no que no tiene que no habla de la
venganza
pues eso es lo que no ha no está bien
definido pero es percibido como una
venganza política probablemente será
habrá que ver como la ignorancia
yo creo que hay una mayor intención
detrás de esto porque por ejemplo está
la idea de algo que ha llevado por
ejemplo a la diputada cima a una
diputada conservadora que del propio
partido conservador que se erigió en la
imagen y la defensora en la figura más
visible de la digamos de la oposición se
oponía a su propio primer ministro por
lo cual por lo cual se vio obligada y
evitable que deje el partido el
conservador y uno podría pensar que ya
que había apoyado una posición de
crítica al gobierno de parte de los neo
demócratas de juego guardián que los neo
demócratas le pedían que se anulen esas
que se mantengan que se mantenga el
financiamiento para los servicios a la
comida francesa entonces ella votó con
ese bloque opositor entonces lo cual la
ponían una situación móvil del
insostenible políticamente así que ella
decidió abandonar el partido y sentarse
y beit de cárcel por el momento una
diputada independiente en la legislatura
de la provincia de ontario y entonces
otro debate esa es también él
universidad de la necesidad francés en
francés en toronto quiere una nueva
universidad contaba con el presupuesto
del gobierno anterior claro de unos 80
millones pero que iba a desembolsarse a
lo largo de 10 años claro en 15 ó 10
años lo cual implicaba que no eran
grandes montos de dinero entonces esto
de alguna forma coincide con esa con esa
con ese elemento presente en los
conservadores tanto federales como
provinciales de oposición al bilingüismo
hubo una recordemos que cuando steven
aprestaban el poder una de las
posiciones de su base era justamente
porque el gobierno tiene que gastar en
servicios a los francófonos se intentó
cortar servicios a los francófonos en
algunas partes del país con argumento de
que bueno van a ver si lo piden no como
un derecho adquirido es decir lo que
ellos pretenden es que los francófonos
se queden como en un gueto en que lean
asimilar los anglófonos en el resto de
canadá ligeros y ciclos de más
francófonos fuera de que el vigente
existe que se asimilen
que se miren a la lengua el primer
ministro de ontario parece que empezó a
retroceder ahora con estas ideas que
tenía debido justamente a las protestas
ya no sólo en su propia provincia sino
en otros lugares de canadá no si
justamente hubo una reacción en todo el
país y pensemos por ejemplo en los
francófonos de manitoba que tienen su
navidad en san bonifacio por ejemplo
ustedes cuando fuimos a nunavut la
población
además que es un país
vivos oficialmente según además difusión
es un país bilingüe entonces si una
reacción en varias partes del país el
propio ministro ya 52 dijo quiero hablar
una ministra ineficiente porque es la
única forma de que manning no jolie
veranillo la mitad del patrimonio que
fue digamos la carga
y quedó como ministra de la francofonía
dijo cosas muy muy muy generales en la
reacción pero esta reacción tanto de
quebec como de otras partes de canadá y
del gobierno federal hicieron que el
gobierno
y dirá que va a financiar esta esta
universidad la universidad parece que sí
parece que la universidad la habana no
la valoran todavía no hay ningún santo
mejor que el problema es porque lo que
lo que por lo que no va a aceptar esa
decisión es ese financiar y esto fue
porque la anterior primera mi primera
ministra
karen guanyant me había prometido eso
como una promesa electoral entonces lo
que los contadores quieren es romper
todo vínculo con lo que hayan hecho los
liberales previamente es más que una
venganza contra los francófonos sería
una venganza contra los liberales es
decir poner a eliminar todo todas las
posibilidades todo lo que les habían
prometido lo que habían puesto sobre la
mesa bueno muy bien entonces estos son
los temas que habíamos tratado la semana
pasada y como hubo pues algunas
novedades es interesante poder darle
continuidad ahora que tienen para contar
ustedes algo que les haya sorprendido
acá en canadá esta semana yo tengo algo
voy a empezar y ese es una es algo
extraño que pasó en columbia británica
en la
provincia en una localidad donde un jefe
de bomberos había puesto una cámara
oculta en su despacho en su oficina
porque el señor sospechaba que los
bomberos entraban a su oficina cuando él
no estaba y les revisaba en cajones y
cosas entonces dijo voy a poner el la
camarita el tema es que hay dos bomberos
que fueron adentro a su oficina hicieron
el amor y todo quedó grabado en la
camarita entonces el jefe de los
bomberos creo que es vernon se llama el
lugar el jefe de bomberos británica ese
es el jefe de bomberos es david lynn de
una localidad de columbia británica
entonces con la prueba en mano en mano
despidió a la pareja de bomberos los los
despidió entonces el sindicato de los
bomberos protesta porque dice que
utilizar cámara oculta es una invasión a
la privacidad de los empleados
y utilizar de la oficina del jefe para
hacer el amor también pero es un segundo
plano
y ahora ocho meses después de este hecho
de que es la camarita esa luz hubiera
filmado a la pareja por haber tenido
relaciones sexuales en la oficina del
jefe los dos bomberos tanto para la
corte no no no van a la corte quieren
recuperar su trabajo y su dignidad
dicen ellos también entonces ustedes qué
les parece ses es la oficina del jefe
eso es la otra oficina no hay otra
oficina de espacio cerrado no le tocaron
los cajones que lo que él tiene dice que
le hurgaban las que lo hicieron sobre el
escritorio tampoco otra otra cosa cuando
que había dicho donde confunde la
palabra cajones así bueno entonces yo
creo que por un lado es ilegal el filmar
a los empleados aunque hay muchas
compañías que inclusive ponen cámaras no
pero él es legal si no está
si no está anunciada anunciado
estamos filmando
todo que era una cámara oculta eso es
cierto sí pero todo hay que ver si era
único espacio privado si estaba en
momento de la pausa no se puede hacer la
pausa
no está donde su pausa y ahí es el único
espacio disponible
hay que pensar que trabajar de bombero
es muy estresante
24 ó 48 horas centro de ir a combatir
los incendios ya yo he visto películas y
6 lo que es a través de las películas
pero yo no me metería ni ni ni loca en
una casa que está ardiendo no bueno
yo también defendería y que además creo
no hurgaron los cajones sino tocar
absolutamente nada 17 a nivel tranquilo
a puerta cerrada justamente a puerta
cerrada él tenía sus sospechas pero no
sabía de qué finalmente pensaba que era
para revisar sus papeles pero no era eso
entonces bueno
el escritorio de habían hecho antes para
el tema es que se van los bomberos éstos
se van a juicio al jefe ahora entonces
el sindicato por supuesto que los
defiende y hay que ver entonces en qué
termina todo esto los amigos y aquí
tenemos dos saludos en realidad jorge en
esto que abre él nos envía cosas para
hablábamos así que de qué se trata lo
que se está enviando capaz que es algo
que él tiene acordarse y después nelson
contras rincón dice buenos días desde
barranquilla colombia internacional y
jeannette betancourt saludos cordiales
al mejor equipo de locutores del pse y
desde quiport nueva jersey
ahora sí van a preguntas como como vemos
en este caso es decir los bomberos que
hicieron el amor en la oficina del jefe
de bomberos están en la vida había una
cámara oculta los filmó y el jefe los
despidió y estos esta pareja de bomberos
ahora quieren recuperar no sólo el
trabajo sino también dice su dignidad y
es la retroactividad también un aumento
[Risas]
de un espacio para los empleados
empleados pero no para hacer el amor
brujo' no se puede pedir eso humana
el empleo del mundo en los muros la
historia es diferente muy diferente
bueno entonces eso fue lo que a mí me
llamó la atención ustedes que tienen
algo que les haya llamado la partida y
hay que decirlo antes de antes de pasar
a otros temas también serios es que hoy
esta mañana se firmó el tratado de libre
comercio canadá méxico eeuu en buenos
aires es un tratado que se viene
negociando hace 15 meses por lo mismo si
llega una apostilla esta mañana en el
programa en francés una persona que
estaba que habló en skype
experto en cuestiones de
no no no no no en cuestiones de comercio
que trabaja en la omct y decía que en
realidad es el tlcan el del canal
disfrazado le llaman el nuevo tele
camper si no sea en realidad básicamente
es lo mismo que tiene un par de cosas
muy interesantes a nivel de cuidar a mí
los derechos los trabajadores y tal en
otras se pierde un poco pero que
básicamente es casi lo mismo en el mismo
tratado pues entonces ahí anteriormente
era se le llamaba este tratado nafta en
inglés tlcan en español malena y alena
en francés ahora se le llama en inglés
los canadienses te llaman asma
por canadá porque dicen que cada país
pone primero su país en la inicial de su
país entonces la cee canadá misma en
méxico le dicen te mex
tratado méxico eeuu canadá y en estados
unidos dicen algo impronunciable
bueno pues primero en todo caso
entonces esto se firmó hoy en buenos
aires dentro del marco de las
actividades de la reunión del g20 que se
está llevando a cabo a mí lo que me
llamó la atención y no tienen que ver
con canadá sino con justamente lo que
está pasando en buenos aires es la
historia de la llegada de macrón
no sé si un papelón es argentino
de coordinación tiempo llegada y
organización
es una cuestión de protocolo pero él
y el señalador de los aviones fue los
saludos super respetuosos me pareció
fantasmas y también él tomara las
riendas se acercó y salió a saludar al
presidente de francia y a su esposa en
esa visita oficial
pero era desolador verla las imágenes de
forma chrome mirando para atrás
y obviamente a mí lo que me llamó la
atención y estaba viendo era también
cómo lo acogieron al príncipe de
heredero de arabia saudita que fue a
buenos aires argentina este g-20 para
haber recomponer su imagen a nivel
internacional están todos los grandes
líderes de los grandes países digo no
grandes líderes sino líderes de grandes
están todos en buenos aires y un poco
fue a ver pues sé si le daban aire para
respirar debido a que él está acusado
por turquía y por pruebas de la silla de
eeuu que analizaron el asesinato del
periodista está mal que yo que si
asesinado en la en el consulado de
arabia saudita en turquía entonces salió
limpito yo creo que salió pasó la prueba
está feliz porque además fue abrazado
pues se lo vio
putin y por supuesto trauma y macri y
todo el mundo como si aquí no pasa nada
no eso es fascinante ver como salman el
destripador ahora se es al man estaba
sonriente pero curioso y no le sucedió
lo que le sucedió a macro y ahí hubiera
podido hacer es que él cuando llegó el
príncipe heredero a buenos aires llegó
y su séquito y la logística para su
desplazamiento en seis aviones
el señor se desplaza de cualquier forma
no tiene plata para tirar lo que la
visita será ya no será lo que es ahora
cuando haya más autos eléctricos y un
dato interesante de un sismo que nunca
había pasado en la ciudad 150 años que
no te pone nervioso a la guerra pero la
cantidad a mí me llama mucho la atención
me da muchísimas gracias lo son gracias
son muy graciosos en contra de macri a
favor de macri en contra de trampa favor
hay de todos hay de todo uno que me
encantó es el g20 en argentina
macri se pone en campaña para que sea je
39.50 el dólar claro por qué
es un chiste obviamente no pero en la
época ejemplo macri estaba el dólar a 20
hasta 39 con 50
dice macri se ocupa de que el g20 sea el
je 39.50 increíble una persona increíble
es la rapidez con la que sacan los memes
son gracias son están imperdibles bueno
tienen algo que destacar ustedes
entonces esta semana bueno yo pues algo
que me pareció curioso es lo encontré en
el sitio de radio canadá y es que en el
hall en la entrada del hotel hilton
quebec en la ciudad de quebec
se ha construido una una pequeña casa
una pequeña casa en la entrada pero lo
curioso y lo interesante con esto es que
la han construido con este pan de
jengibre que es muy popular en épocas
entonces se dice que van a ser iguales
cerca cuál es el destino de esa casa
bueno pues se la van a comer me imagino
nos dicen acá es como elvis
los preparo con harina melaza y mucha
azúcar 900 kilos de todos estos
ingredientes tamaño tiene esa casa de
[Música]
4.2 metros
es la estructura está hecha de madera
pero está recubierta con este este pan
de jengibre se utilizaron 2.400 al
ladrillos de pan de jengibre y 2.900
texas en el mismo material
entonces explora lo que falta lo único
que falta es comercial bueno quizá
iniciativa a ver pronto la próxima
hembra habrá un encuentro de médicos
especializados en diabetes
bueno y rufo tienes algo si justamente
algo que me llama la atención fue un
fallo de la corte suprema este viernes
un fallo que tendrá consecuencias
justamente se trata de un periodista del
grupo mediático vice que comenzó como
una con un programa de gobierno de la
provincia de québec para jóvenes
drogadictos pero que se convirtió en una
en un mamut de la comunicación a nivel
mundial entonces un periodista de esta
organización bein makos había logrado
entrar en contacto con un canadiense
para ser donde el federal canadiense
entró en contacto con él pues no sé
quién entró en claro con quién pero lo
concreto es que entra en el contrato a
través de una red una plataforma
justamente como whatsapp pero que una
plataforma que se llama kick pero que no
deja ninguna huella a caramba en las que
se cree pero no es así si si deja
huellas pero en los aparatos no en el no
en el sistema entonces lo que ocurre es
que gracias a esos contactos este
periodista logra
información solvente done y escribe tres
artículos y luego aparecen imágenes en
que este joven en de calgary en canadá
en sede veinte años y entró ésta se lo
dé y lo vimos todos en cámaras que mandó
su pasaporte canadiense como hay un
grupo en reunión de propaganda del grupo
armado el estado islámico en irak y
siria entonces la policía federal quería
obtener esa comunicación para poder
llevar a cabo el intercambio de
comunicaciones detenciones y el
periodista se negó siempre a dar esta
información pero la policía real montada
dice que necesita esa información los
previos que le dieron la razón a la
policía sí pero ahora es la corte
suprema corte suprema donante suprema
dice que tiene que entregar esos datos y
además un fallo unánime así que lo que
estaba el cual sería la cámara entre
hasta qué punto
el tiempo se debe proteger el derecho
del estado a investigar actividades
criminales y cuando llega el derecho de
los periodistas a guardar la identidad
entonces en este caso justo el caso es
un caso para mí difícil estamos hablando
de un terrorista canadiense un
combatiente porque eso de terrorista
en fin para mí una persona que tiene una
bomba es un terrorista
esté del lado que esté rufo que no hay
que entrar mantener a entran muchos
bueno es considerado en todo caso en
canadá como un terrorista que un
combatiente que fue a luchar por el
estado isla no pero no pasó con él con
el ataque de san bernardino en eeuu que
no quería dar la posibilidad que
abrieran el teléfono justamente porque
era privado el teléfono de alguien que
había cometido una masacre y ya como
empresa de eeuu y el gobierno
hizo enfrentamientos legales con apple
para poder finalmente lo saquearon al
teléfono pero apple no dio el acceso
para poder entrar porque es una cuestión
de privacidad
en defensa de sí pero es cuando es una
cuestión como dijo hay rufo también este
es una cuestión también de hasta donde
debes proteger los intereses del estado
frente a una información que te puede
servir vídeo y la privacidad guardar esa
información de la fuente a para mí es un
caso muy difícil este es difícil porque
por ejemplo la información que se tiene
de a priori es que ha sido era es un
terrorista que fue cometido con el gesto
islámico pero por ejemplo en afganistán
y en siria
ahí hay canadienses que han ido a
combatir a las tropas extranjeras no
porque estén a favor de estadista mico
sino porque están con la idea de que no
quieren tropas extranjeras en su
territorio está bien flujo pero no nos
desviamos de esto colocar a lo que me
refiero es que hay la corte suprema de
canadá es un fallo unánime
justamente general la corte suprema de
canadá no tiene es ecuánime si es
ecuánime y la razón fundamental que
y que plantea el juez mitchell moldea
era la única no había otra forma de
obtener esa información que era la única
forma de obtener esa información era
yendo a esos archivos de comunicación en
los aparatos de este periodista que en
este caso anteriormente había indicado
que estaba inclusive dispuesto ir a la
cárcel para defender el derecho a la
privacidad de sus fuentes pero ante un
fallo de la corte suprema no sé cómo el
cual que lo que alternativas tienen de
todas maneras el por qué es la corte
suprema este este muchacho canadiense
acaba de ver tal por los 28 años no sé
cuánto tendrá eso pasó hace cuando 2014
y él tenía 20 años 20 años tiene 24 en
cinco años
dónde está el estado que murió en un
bombardeo
supuestamente habríamos hacer un
bombardeo y de gestión y de que tengo un
mensaje en vender terminando habiendo
terminado con el tema un mensaje de
nelson contra el rincón con respecto a
lo de los bomberos y dice pienso que las
sanciones impuestas
quizás una suspensión del empleo por
unos días hubiese sido suficiente con el
permiso de no volverlo a hacer la corte
suprema si lo demás ya está como un no
puede controlar sus impulsos dentro de
24 ó 48 horas 72 horas de trabajo
continuo y teniendo un solo lugar donde
poder ir
pero también hay baños no
[Risas]
claro ahí había algunas golosinas
también
buscaban la comodidad que tenemos que
conocer los detalles vamos a conversar
ahora no sé si alguien tiene algo más
que quieras si no vamos a ir a los temas
porque no nos van a quedar no nos va a
quedar más tiempo los temas que ustedes
destacan que destacamos todos esta
semana voy a empezar leonardo con vos
porque tienes un boom vas a hablarnos de
un reloj de upper que te mejora la salud
a largo plazo en realidad la historia es
un estudio encargado por una aseguradora
y una empresa muy grande que hace este
tipo de estudios donde hicieron una
investigación dando como recompensa el
mismo reloj está bien o sea yo te
entrego el reloj
y tienes que pagar 22 dólares con 50
aproximadamente era el cambio eran euros
la historia por mes podrías no pagarlos
si cumples con el ejercicio del reloj
que pide y la gente hizo los ejercicios
y mejoró su calidad de vida es fueron
400.000 personas que hicieron esto y a
través del estudio en general se
comprobó que uno hacía 4.8 de días más
de ejercicios que normalmente
en personas la muestra sobre personas
que tenían problemas de alimentación que
eran obesos o que tenían sobrepeso y les
ha mejorado muchísimo la calidad de vida
entonces digamos la asociación directa
es un reloj como estos inteligentes
puede a uno mejorar la vida es como que
te están controlando a pensar y tienen
porque viene pero tengo neurológico de
esto y tiene tiene un sistema de
entrenamiento que a uno
por ejemplo es hora de que te levantes y
yo inconscientemente digo tendría que
levantarme y me levanto voy a buscar una
fotocopia o voy a tomar buscar un vaso
de agua una taza de café y al final del
día me dice lo logras te hiciste tanto
movimiento por día y xbox o sea que el
instituto ahora es un tutor alguien que
le va diciendo a uno qué hacer y eso
mejora la calidad de la vida de las
personas su director técnico exacto
exacto y me funciona y a mí no hubo
ningún tuvo que pagar el gel del para
nadie me lo regaló sino en el caso ese
es interesante porque digamos si bien
estaba pagado o uno tenía que evitar
pagar y por eso hacia los ejercicios que
dice el estudio que este tipo de
prácticas se hace permanente es decir
uno empezó durante dos años porque tenía
que pagar o no pagar el reloj pero uno
queda con los buenos hábitos entonces
que evidentemente estas tecnologías
ayudan al crecimiento de la persona y
ayudan a mantener la salud de la persona
este teléfono puede medir el corazón el
pulso cardíaco y un debate en eeuu
justamente porque si bien en canadá la
educa es el sistema de salud es público
en eeuu es a partir de seguros y hay
compañías de seguro médico que
ofrecieron estos relojes a sus empleados
y que al aceptar esa condenado porque no
lo que lo que propone es que les vamos a
rebajar la prima que tienen que pagar
por su seguro porque de esa forma claro
le podrían contratar a cuestionar a
quien se quedaba con información y si
había que es una información médica
entonces si estoy donde iba a acabar y
cómo se iba a utilizar esta información
entonces ese es el elemento que
específicamente todo el mundo tiene
acceso a todos los datos a los médicos
tampoco son más católicos que el papá
que muchas veces ocultan información o
la manejan para proteger y hablando de
información justamente pablo vos no vas
a hablar de un tema de sheen
no hay una película colombiana que es
sobre los implantes mamarios bueno que
era una chica que quería de hacerse unos
implantes mamarios para salir de la
pobreza y llegó a eso llevo bueno lo que
sucede es que el consorcio internacional
de periodistas de investigación que es
un consorcio del cual forma parte radio
canadá y vice y el diario toronto star
es ese consorcio de periodismo de
investigación empezaron a estudiar los
los dispositivos médicos los
dispositivos médicos y como justamente
los médicos ellos mismos y las clínicas
y los hospitales y todas estas entidades
que supuestamente tienen que vigilar y
cuidar la salud de las personas
no lo hacen y ellos entre otros el
anoche en el programa del periodismo de
investigación de aquí de la casa de
radio canadá en el programa aunque
pasaron justamente es una parte del
trabajo y estudiaron muchos dispositivos
pero entre otros los implantes mamarios
los implantes mamarios que muchas
compañías hay varios fabricantes que lo
producen y que ellos tenían que hacer
rendir cuentas a la sda a la fota and
drug administration de estados y a salud
del ministerio de salud de canadá sobre
la evolución de estos implantes porque
se había autorizado en un momento dado
que se hizo muy popular los implantes
mamarios no sólo en norteamérica sino en
todo el mundo en todo el mundo pero no
se hicieron conscientemente todas las
investigaciones que tenían que hacerse
para saber cuál es el seguimiento del
impacto que esos implante
mamarios y van a tener en la salud de
las mujeres en particular con el tiempo
es el ministerio de salud de canadá
había propuesto que se hiciera un
estudio longitudinal durante 10 años con
40 mil mujeres no para después de eso
aprobar la utilización de esos implantes
y finalmente no se es el seguimiento en
un poco porque se comenzó se hicieron el
estudio que más duro duró 44 años pues
que más duro y lo que los fabricantes de
estos implantes decía era que se le
perdieron el rastro de 80 por ciento de
las mujeres que estaban participando en
en el estudio se desprende de eso como
consecuencia que estos implantes algunos
se se deterioraron durante el tiempo es
que tuvieron el cuerpo de la mujer otros
se regó la silicona en el pecho y la
consecuencia más importante es que
ha creado un nuevo cáncer es un cáncer
que ha sido creado por el hombre
bueno pues que ha atacado existe en 659
casos de esos cáncer de los cuales 25
aquí en canadá
no no no saben todavía ni siquiera cómo
combatirlo porque es algo nuevo
entonces las entrevista van a médicos y
especialistas una investigación que fue
en 59 países casi 60 países y que duró
18 meses es una investigación muy seria
recién ahora están saliendo los
resultados de esa investigación y visto
como un mapa donde la gente puede entrar
a su país donde si es uno de los países
elegidos para la investigación iba a
tener la información entonces esto es
una alerta lo que están lanzando para
toda la gente que tiene estos
dispositivos en las rodillas
gastrointestinal intestinales en el
corazón todos esos aparatos extraños que
te ponen en el cuerpo igual tiene que
ver con el comercio de la medicina eso
si yo me acuerdo cuando por primera vez
pensé en operarme los ojos mi oculista
en argentina me dijo no porque operarse
los ojos para ver mejor lo que estás
haciendo tocando un órgano sano y lo
estás corrigiendo para corregir una
deformación no un problema no es una
enfermedad la miopía es un problema
si estás tocando un órgano para
corregirlo un año más tarde con programa
quienes bajen lo más seguro del mundo y
bueno dice
desde desde cuándo y ustedes fíjense que
a toda la gente que opera de los ojos
por ejemplo tratando un tema porque me
interese en eso de nuevo hace un par de
meses atrás que ofrecen gratis claro
pero tienen todos tienen lentes la gente
que opera no se opera los ojos
claro entonces bueno esto una cuestión
de comercio yo creo que estamos tan
metidos en una cuestión comercial dentro
de la de la medicina que busquen o no
nos podemos salir para terminar muy
rápidamente ss de eso trata el tema y
esa investigación pues sigue en curso y
ahora muchas mujeres las mujeres que a
las 25 mujeres que sufren del cáncer
aquí en canadá quieren que el ministerio
de salud de canadá les rinda cuentas y
que diga porque tienen ahora ellos ella
ese problema y el ministerio nunca ha
reaccionado muy bien gracias pablo
flujos si nos vas a hablar del reggae si
ahora el sueño cultural de la unesco d
brevemente este título es interesante a
ese título sin tetas no hay paraíso es
una telenovela colombiana en la que una
mujer catalina aquí viene de pereira y
es lo que explica pablo pero para qué
porque quiere ser prepago que es una
prostituta y esta es una prueba 112
trabajos más logrados de la narcocultura
en la cultura colombiana y en toda
américa latina entonces un título
bastante revelador de cómo esa cultura
impregna otros espacios de la sociedad
en la que justamente fue declarado la
música está patrimonio cultural de la
humanidad así se encuentra el grupo fue
la iniciativa ésta rufo fue inactiva del
propio gobierno jamaiquino que planteó
está educada país puede proponer hay hay
cosas en una memoria que emana que ya
propuso creo el marte el tango por
ejemplo algo el mate y mate etcétera
entonces propusieron que el reiki sea
reconocido como patrimonio intangible de
la humanidad y esto le pone a la altura
del jazz por ejemplo y la unesco si hace
toda esa propuesta a partir de una serie
de elementos pero sobre todo a partir de
cómo esta música es capaz de cumplir con
lo que la música hace y la descripción
era muy interesante que la música que
cumple con ese rol de poder ser a la vez
una catarsis colectiva un instrumento de
documentar la vida cotidiana y también
de expresar los sentimientos de un
pueblo de un pueblo y que existe un poco
recorrido del reggae también aquí en
canadá sus foros y justamente el rey los
años 50 60 70 es interesante notar que
cuando que nada cambia sus leyes de
inmigración porque se necesita mano de
obra barata entonces si antes se
favorecía la emigración europea en los
años 50 decidí abrir la migración a la
población no blanca que viene del caribe
anglófono y que tiene y que tiene como
centro de llegada a la ciudad de toronto
entonces a partir de esos años empieza a
surgir el rey y como resultado de esas
políticas inmigratorias y aparecen
grupos como
varios grupos de kavalier que hay un
gran desayuno acá también que nombraste
el chango de chango familia que ya está
en tres lenguas y que justamente
recuperan ese tema de una de una de una
de un posicionamiento político es
cuestionan porque eso es música que
viene de los de abajo por decir nada por
usar una palabra pero también de los
inmigrantes de los arrabales de abajo el
tango es así nacional sí aunque mejor
los tangos de evita por ejemplo de
revolución etcétera entonces ocurre lo
mismo estamos ejes que perpetúa que hace
parte ahora no hay ciudad canadiense
imagínate uno de los grupos que
nominados para los y uno en que nada ni
de alberta porque claro lo que a veces
una mujer entonces es una música que
también hoy es parte de la cultura
canadiense pues excelente bay y además
en este reportaje ruffa en uruguay
música que pusiste en la música así pues
y hablando justamente de d
música para aquellos los que quieren
escuchar el programa en nuestro sitio
web ynet punto osea encontré una música
que no tiene nada que ver o si también
con lo que está mencionando rüffer
reggae encontré un cantante y nuit y no
perdón quebequenses a with se llama
cantan creo el francés inglés pero sobre
todo en su idioma nativo y no y es un
artista que mezcla justamente el reggae
y el dancehall y el soul con él y no hay
mon que es su lengua materna entonces si
no bueno ya no estamos más en internet
digo en facebook voy porque ya pasamos
el tiempo pero igual en la emisión que
estamos grabando lo que quería era un
comentario de guill en abril que dice
muchas gracias por hablar de los
desafíos de la población francófona de
canadá que vive al exterior de quebec
somos aquí dice ella somos aquí desde
siempre y debemos seguir luchando para
conservar nuestros derechos
constitucional muchísimas gracias a uno
la próxima semana esperando el próximo
ya muchísimas gracias será hasta la
próxima semana
el próximo adiós